the Dow Jones Industrial Average started
the day at another record high the fifth
straight and closing in on another
milestone the blue chip index gained
nearly 73 points yesterday finishing
just below the 22,000 mark the dow is up
more than eleven percent this year the
president tweeted yesterday morning
stock market could hit all-time high
again CBS news financial contributor
Mellody Hobson is in Chicago melody
goodmorning past presidents have been
hesitant to take credit for a stock
market gains saying you know it's harder
to control that than it is economic
programs is it fair for the president to
be taking credit here well I think that
I subscribe to the point of view of
warren buffett who is that one of the
greatest investors of all time who's
been known to say markets are stronger
than governments I think at the end of
the day this market has been fueled by
fundamentals in this country corporate
profits are expected to be up 11% in the
second quarter
corporations are doing great Americans
are working unemployment is at four
point three percent and who would have
thought that when eight years ago we
were at 10 percent and then the rest of
the world is actually holding up pretty
well who would have thought we would see
pockets of strength in Europe and China
which many have that thought would be
winding down or slowing down seems to be
holding up okay so I don't think it's
just about the White House I think it
really is more about the fundamentals of
businesses globally does that mean that
in fact they expect this to continue
that there is no push back that will
restrain it in the future in the long
term as you know Charlie bull markets
follow bear markets and you know nothing
goes straight up there's that saying
trees don't grow to the sky this has
been a phenomenal period I mean I don't
think anyone expected this kind of
strength anywhere coming off of such a
long run that we have had this is the
second longest run since World War two
so this is quite strong but at the end
of the day of course are going to be
there we have to expect some pole bath
backs at some point maybe some of that
will come if some of the policies that
have been talked about in our price den
like lower taxes
don't come through maybe that'll happen
if we don't see some of the dealer
deregulation that has been discussed car
sales are declining car sales have been
down but I actually think that's not an
economic story I think that's about
right sharing companies I think that's
about Ober and lists and the fact that
those companies have people saying why
buy a car when I can dial one up but we
live in a time of uncertainty too and we
don't really know what's gonna come out
of Washington we've seen the president
be unsuccessful so far in passing
legislation that uncertainty sometimes
cause businesses not to invest that's
right uncertainty is never good for the
market it's never good for any business
however what this market seems to be
telling us is again the fundamentals are
very strong and as a result of that it
continues to power through anything can
happen anything has happened but the one
thing I believe when it comes to
capitalism is that at the end of the day
we are looking at an upward trajectory
for this country and for the world
Nights melody great to have you thanks